what is up reject nation so we just put
out a video talking about a couple of
marvel
news rumors but then we saw that this
was out and i was like well
well yeah well yeah yeah yeah and i got
a spiderman
number huh a real plot leak and
multiverse confirmed
let's see what's in store shall we oh
let's do it
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder a
ton of spider-man news has happened over
the last few days and at this point it's
all getting pretty official marvel has
been trying
so hard to keep the spider-verse in no
way home a secret but at this point in
time with the actors themselves
confirming that they'll be in the film
and confirming the multiverse
marvel is happening thank you alfred
molina
but good for them for trying so we have
the confirmation of the multiverse
confirmation of not one but two villains
one of which is rumored to be the main
villain and we have a plot leak from
somebody who has proved accurate in his
leagues before
and i'm gonna break it all down ooh
scoopers
alfred molina who of course played dr
octavius and spider-man 2 the original
one with toby mcguire has
publicly come out and stated that he is
indeed
going to be in spider-man no way home
and not only did he come out stating
that he's going to be in the film
he said that it's going to be the same
character from the same sam raimi
universe
he said that his story is going to pick
up again right where it left off
at the end of spider-man that is
multiverse confirmation baby it's very
interesting because we
technically didn't see him die we
assumed so
way back then in 2004 but saving grace
was really a thing geek media kind of
stay alive
and that's actually what alfred molina
said the director told him
he said he asked john watts the director
how he's going to come back
if he died in which john watts replied
in this universe
no one really dies which is true we now
have time travel and the multiverse
there's ways to get around it yeah i
think that line from john watts kind of
undercuts some stuff we already have
that feeling
that deaths are not as concrete in the
marvel cinematic universe but for the
director
of one of the biggest marvel properties
to come out and say that it's like come
on man i'm excited about offer molino's
coming back but
i'm hoping that it doesn't undercut his
ark that was in spider-man 2 considering
that this
is going to be following the canon of
that specific dock you know what i mean
absolutely yeah then the article
specifically says in their early
conversations alfred molina said that
john watts told him that the movie will
pick up
doc ock's story from that moment in the
river which in a franchise that includes
multiverses
time travel and diverging timeline seems
plausible enough
they'll have to
and take him into a different universe
our universe and that's how he becomes
one of the villains or perhaps even
maybe somewhat of a hero
in no way home and the same probably
goes for jamie foxx's electro as well
now as i mentioned we have a spider-man
no way home plot league today yeah what
are you talking about
actually really cool because this leak
is coming from somebody who
leaked the information about the secret
cameo that was in the falcon and the
winter soldier episode five
this particular oh
louise you've done it for me lately
lately last week and now they have a
plot leak for us reliability
says the movie starts off where far from
home ended and
there is a time skip peter is in court
and there is a lot going on
he is trying to prove his innocence
doctor strange calls out that there is
something going on and the multiverse is
breaking so in court has to be he's
being represented by the mountain
right yeah murdoch villains are going
around from other worlds
into others kind of jumping world to
world and they're specifically your
villains
yes spider-man put them in a special
made prison
by him the villain somehow escaped
because tom holland's peter parker
messes with some stuff probably in the
sanctum sanctorum
toby mcguire's peter parker and andrew
garfield's peter parker are in the
second
and third act of the movie and the
leaker states that how they met or how
they came into tom holland's world is
unknown to him
but both toby maguire's peter parker and
andrew garfield's peter parker help out
tom hollins peter parker and doctor
strange in rounding up the villains in
their world
the leaker says there are scenes in the
movie with
just toby mcguire and andrew garfield oh
no way
so it's not just going to be team-up
scenes according to this leaker we're
actually going to get some one-on-one
time with the previous spider-man
it goes on oh man i i love that if we
get
isolated scenes or just them
individually if there's a scene i'm
really craving
obviously i want to see all three of
them together i love the idea that i'm
random enough guys and
just the the shots the shots of all
right all the angles the rash pages all
those
moving epic shots of the three of them
swinging but i am desiring a scene just
between toby maguire and andrew garfield
i know yeah i want to see just them
interacting with each other
every possible combination it goes on to
say spider-man movies final act
is on the statue of liberty that now
looks like a big captain america with
the shield no
this is actually something that we've
seen a very recent leaked
set photo for oh
liberty well that's because
spider-man no way home picks up right
now dude
that's great yeah dude and we know that
spider-man is better than last week
takes place
six months after avengers end game and
so does the falcon and the winter
soldier
so it is possible that this is all
happening right when john walker is
named
the new captain america to me this makes
the most sense because why else would
they decorate the statue of liberty
like captain america unless they were
celebrating captain america
and the announcement of a new captain
america we've already seen has been
greeted with
parades marching bands and the new
captain america is supposed to be a
symbol of hope
to america and the world so they most
likely dressed up the statue of liberty
to commemorate this i'm just wondering
if i like the idea of a set piece at the
statue of liberty and let that be like a
cool finale showdown i don't think we've
really
seen that seen spider-man events with
like certain famous bridges and all that
the statue of liberty and especially
with the captain america shield i'm
hoping that there'll be some actual
meaning and symbolism that plays into it
and not just a cool
looking set piece i mean you know
because the statue of liberty seems like
a prime place for captain america
characters to fight or
or yeah something that's going to dive
into you know what the statue means and
the fact that we're fighting at it being
significant
i guess seems like maybe a stretch for
just like how much this movie has
already to do but it would be nice if
they had some subjects
it goes on to say that all of the
villains are there with tom holland
spider-man
toby maguire spider-man and andrew
garfield wow that shot
is present in the scene and every
villain is trying to get their hands on
it for something
the leaker says that based on what they
saw that part was not very clear
but all of the villains go on to be
defeated and are put back in the prison
of dr strange
all of them accept willem dafoe's green
goblin
but they go on to say that the green
goblin goes on to kill somebody major
the leaker is not sure who this person
is but we just
talked about who that might be tries to
kill the green goblin but wasn't
successful in doing so in the end
the movie ends with peter parker
finishing high school and it's not clear
on what happens to toby maguire and
andrew garfield spider-man
they also look for the player wait wait
whoa so he finishes
high school at the end he's got all that
look i just need to graduate well no
that'll be yeah this is
another time skip guys i have to get
back to class
it's the rush man no i imagine like a
coda where everything the dust is
settled and he's you know at school
thinking about like wow now i'm just
back in a normal scenario
being a kid i guess i gotta grow up
after all these crazy adventures
and again talking about how i don't
wanted to undercut the doc ox story line
goblin died a villain the thing though
is is goblin's death
really had major ripple effects for toby
maguire
spider-man so if goblin is coming in
here if it is for sure willem dafoe i'm
expecting to see some [ __ ] of
toby maguire having an emotional
response to all this oh yeah that's
gonna catch especially
especially if there's a major death and
then tom holland spider-man wants to
kill him or science like tempted to
there's got to be some type of
mentorship thing kind of reminding us of
a spider-verse and if they do include
him it seems like they are
including more of the toby verse
villains perhaps than the andrew
garfield or anything like that so it
seems like they're heaping some
significance on that so
what if it's been dehon this whole time
he's finally gonna get his
dude that green goblin's coming back now
there have been a few reports talking
about norman osborne's green goblin
returning for spider-man no way home
this plot leak actually isn't the first
time that we've heard this
however this plot leak does back it up
and recently a twitter account that has
been right about some previous leaks in
the past has been stating that willem
dafoe's green goblin is indeed the main
villain
of spiderman no way home now we did
indeed see
green goblin die in the very first
spider-man but like john watts said
nobody's really dead in this universe
they could very well grab him before he
dies or perhaps just like is happening
in the main mcu timeline the reality is
breaking in other
timelines after all we are getting jamie
foxx's electro in spider-man no way home
and it definitely looked like he died in
the amazing spider-man 2
although he could have been teleported
to a different universe
obviously not much is known about how
everything is going to happen and go
down in spider-man no way home but this
plot leak is a great start
look the timeline of the tobey mcguire
films have to be kept intact i'm very
particular about that not only was
norman osborne killed
he also was buried at the end of that
movie yeah there's a funeral for him
yes you know so if you like take him out
of that moment when he dies by his own
glider
then the events of spider-man 2 happen
and like how can you take
toby at any point or you know did this
all happen
individually are they going to disregard
spider-man 3 and in total because i
heard sandman might be in this too and
the other confusing thing to me then is
that also they've confirmed her
a while ago that jamie foxx's electro
would have a different
look and thus be sort of altered from
that movie whereas it also seems like
the tobey maguire villains are going to
be like the exact
same so part of me wonders if they might
actually go
some kind of alternate route but still
use willem defoe or something i don't
know
because if toby is coming in and andrew
it is a sequel to those movies as well
hopefully it's all true like i said this
leaker was right about the falcon and
the winter soldier episode 5
cameo so they seem to be pretty legit so
at this point in time we know that jamie
foxx's electro is going to be returning
willem dafoe's green goblin is most
likely returning in alfred molino's
doctor octavius
is going to be returning as well and
alfred molina in his interview basically
confirming the wonders for us
and of course if i hear anything else
regarding spider-man no way home or
any other marvel news i'll get it out so
be sure to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest videos
be sure to let me know what you think
about this plot leak and alfred molina
confirming the multiverse let me know in
the comments down below don't forget to
like the video and for live updates you
can follow me on instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof all right well i believe that
one way more than the other one that one
actually sounds like a real movie in
focus
and i'm like okay yeah that makes sense
villains are coming in
and then you have the other spider-man
he's got to team up with take on the
multi-villains like this
this sounds like what a lot of us
imagine it would probably be like and
this sounds like it could be a real
movie the one that came out before we
were saying in the middle of the
reaction like we don't buy this this
sounds like a little too ridiculous
yeah if this is a fake theory then good
job
this is the most unbelievable plausible
one because it didn't feel like you're
throwing everything in there to just see
what sticks yeah and considering who the
source is
every leaker almost everyone has been
right about stuff in the past and then
they're wrong about something so just
because this person was right about val
and falcon a winter soldier does not
necessarily mean he's 100 right about
this either
yeah so we'll see we'll see either way
this got me excited like hearing this i
was like
this sounds awesome yeah yeah yeah you
can see that it starts to form the
potential
it flows it already flows in the idea of
how you're pitching it yeah
all right guys well what do you think
about this are you hoping this is the
way this all unfolds leave your thoughts
down below
subscribe click that notification bell
hit that like button and last but not
least
adelia chamberlain adelia you have been
stepping out of your comfort zone so
much for the long time i've known you've
had a lot of great
amazing thoughts that you are wonderful
at articulating when you're typing or
putting the pen to the pad
yet i've always wanted you to kind of be
more on camera and do things like that
especially since you've been so drawn to
people who do that and i've been seeing
you on social media doing a lot more
on camera work i am so proud of you for
stepping out of your comfort zone
taking that initiative to allow yourself
to grow during such a challenging time
you are an inspiration i love you
seriously this is a major major major
step it might feel a little to you to
certain degrees but
really for the individual i know this is
beautiful this is amazing thing and i'm
so proud of you so keep it up and i hope
to see you leading your own channel one
day
kick ass